- I went to all these amazing
dinners before the Oscars.
I met Danny Elfman who
said, "You’re gonna get it",
but still was unsure.
And whole of India
was cheering.
I felt like a gladiator.
(gentle music)
- And the Oscar goes to
A.R. Rahman,
(crowd cheers and claps)
for "Slumdog Millionaire"
- When they announced
my name for the score,
I was like, "Is this
real or is it a dream?"
And because I had
to perform next,
I was like, “A.R, don't react.”
“Just be like the zen mode.”
“Don't mess up your performance.”
(camera clicks)
My speech was not prepared.
I said, "I'll go with the flow."
Maximum I would say thank you and go off.
But when I was sitting there,
I was watching Penelope
Cruz speaking Spanish.
(speaking Spanish)
- Thank you so much.
- Then I was like,
"Oh, that's cool."
I want to say something
in Tamil, which says,
(speaks Tamil).
That means, all perfect
praise belongs to God alone.
It is from a holy book.
It's a promise from God.
Thank you.
That if you remember in
the happy times,
I'll remember you in
the sad times, so.
That is the happiest time
of my own life
and I wanted to remember the
God who's common to all of us.
- And the Oscar goes to...
- A.R. Rahman and Gulzar
for "Jai Ho".
(crowd cheers and claps)
- The second time when
they announced my name
for the best song.
The essence of the film
which is about optimism
and the power of hope
in our lives.
I had said in the speech
that the essence of the
film is optimism and hope
because the world
was going through
that depression,
economic depression
and "Slumdog Millionaire"
was done in a way
that anybody who sees it would feel high.
All my life I've had a
choice of hate and love.
I chose love and I'm here.
God bless.
Some people have
misinterpreted that statement
over some religion and this
and that, which is not true.
This is the state of
every artist in the world
and that's what makes
them the artist.
They want to give and love
is about giving, not taking.
After I got the Oscars, I
put it in my hand baggage
and the security, when
I was getting to India,
they said, "Can you wait?"
And they were almost like 100
people in the security check.
So the officer took
these two Oscars.
"Look what I have", and
everybody went gaga.
They were just, "Oh my God".
(gentle music)